bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur Public
Sénat voici le programme de votre
après-midi dans un instant vous allez
pouvoir suivre les travaux de la
commission spéciale du Sénat sur la
délimitation des régions audition cet
après-midi de l'Assemblée des
départements de France et de
représentants de l'AMF l'Association des
maires de France à 18h15 preuve par 3
l'émission politique de la rédaction de
Public Sénat qui reçoit ce soir Pierre
Laurent secrétaire national du Parti
communiste français et sénateur de Paris
et puis on se retrouve à 19h pour 24
heures Sénat le journal nous
poursuivrons notre série consacrée à
l'examen de la réforme pénale un
reportage sera suivi d'un débat avec les
sénateurs Jean-Pierre Michel Jean-René
le cerf et Yves detreigne mais on
commence par une visite attendue gratin
au groupe UMP du Sénat les trois anciens
premiers ministres qui composent le
désormais célèbre triumvira devait
intervenir devant à les sénateurs
finalement seul Jean-Pierre Raffarin et
François Fillon étaient présents à la
Juppé ayant été retenus à Bordeaux à
cause des grèves alors parmi les thèmes
abordés la crise à l'UMP mais aussi les
investitures pour à laisser la torial
écouter à ce propos aux gens Claude
Gaudin président du groupe
UMP au Sénat au micro de Maxime Tully
nous avons reçu Fillon il y a
aujourd'hui l'équipe de trois
personnalités qui s'occupent de l'UMP
avec le secrétaire général Luc Châtel
nous leur faisons confiance et nous
voulons l'apaisement et nous voulons
préparer les élections qui auront lieu
dans notre partie mais après les
élections
sénatoriales l'objectif pour nous c'est
la réélection de nos sénateurs
UMP et la conquête de la Haute Assemblée
si on peut
autre temps fort de l'actualité aussi
ici au Sénat c'est la visite officielle
d'Isabelle Allende Bussi présidente du
Sénat chilien elle a été accueillie par
Jean-Pierre Bel le président du Sénat
l'occasion pour la première femme
présidente du Sénat de présenter les
réformes menées tambour battants par une
autre femme la présidente Michel
Bachelet on l'écoute au micro de Camila
campusano
la commission spéciale du Sénat sur la
délimitation des régions débute ses
travaux cet après-midi elle entend
donner la parole aux représentant des
élus locaux on va tout de suite
retrouver tam-tran uni avec le sénateur
UMP de la Seine-et-Marne Jean-Jacques
yes c'est lui qui préside cette
commission spéciale
oui Delphine je suis donc avec
Jean-Jacques Yeste bonjour bonjour vous
présidez donc cette commission spéciale
sur la réforme territoriale dont la
première partie va être examinée au
Sénat dès le début du mois de juillet
alors les travaux de la commission des
lois sur cette réforme territoriale
avait débuté dès la semaine dernière
d'ailleurs de nombreux sénateurs
fêtaient venus assister à ses auditions
alors pourquoi fallait-il donc
constituer une commission
spécialement un certain nombre de
collègues et de groupes ont demandé la
constitution d'une commission spéciale
donc c'est de droit qu'à partir du
moment où c'est une volonté majoritaire
des groupes du Sénat quelle est l'apport
de cette commission spéciale par rapport
à la commission des lois
je vous le dirai à la sortie il s'agit
de en fait pour le texte concernant leur
découpage des régions évidemment c'est
pas du tout pareil qu'un texte sur les
compétences qui ou les commissions des
lois est habituée à travailler sur ces
sujets c'est un sujet qui est à la fois
très politique il faut bien le dire et
et qui d'abord mais aurait mérité même
si un étude d'impact qui nous paraît a
beaucoup d'égards en ce qui me concerne
insuffisante
aurait été quand même que ça ne soit pas
fait à la hussarde oui parce que
justement le délai entre l'examen enfin
le passage du texte on conseille des
ministres mi-juin et le début de
l'examen au Sénat début juillet très
court seulement 15 jours alors qu'aller
vous faire pendant ces 15 jours et quel
est votre programme de l'audition
comment allez-vous pouvoir préparer ce
texte on va tenir compte bien sûr des
auditions qu'elle a procédé le
rapporteur puisque c'est le même
rapporteur qui était celui de la
commission des lois Michel Delbarre les
auditions qui ont été faites la semaine
dernière
nos collègues en disposent la plupart de
des membres de la connaissance spéciale
était d'ailleurs présent aux auditions
du ministre et du président de et des
présidents de conseil régionaux donc on
va en tenir compte bien entendu et puis
cet après-midi on a un certain nombre
d'auditions les départements les
communautés l'Association des maires de
France on va se faire une opinion du
sentiment des associations d'élus sur
cette réforme sur cette partie très
forme parce que en fait
un ensemble pourquoi faire des grandes
régions si on ne se pose pas la question
des compétences et beaucoup de sénateurs
s'interrogent d'ailleurs et je vous
rappelle qu'il y avait une mission
d'information qui avait été présidée par
Jean-Pierre Raffarin est rapporté par
Yves cratinger qui disait oui à des
grandes régions avec les enjeux
stratégiques mais maintiens des
départements c'est pas tout à fait ce
que dit le projet de loi le second qui
sera examiné après le renouvellement du
Sénat alors vous n'avez également pas eu
gain de cause sur la procédure accélérée
qui demeure sur ce texte néanmoins a
priori cette procédure accélérée n'est
là que pour raccourcir le délai entre le
moment du passage en conseil des
ministres et le début de l'examen au
Parlement il devrait quand même y avoir
deux lectures par chambre à ce que de ça
vous réjouissez quand même la bonne des
choses parce que là franchement ça
aurait été ça aurait voulu dire bon bah
il y a c'est comme ça et puis vous votez
ou votre départ en plus c'est toujours
difficile quand il y a une seule lecture
à l'Assemblée au Sénat il n'y a pas de
dialogue entre les deux assemblées en
fait il y en a mais qui est quand même
assez fictif en commission mix paritaire
donc c'est indispensable que pour ces
sujets là mais c'est vrai aussi de la
contrainte pénale ou il y a le procédure
accéléré il y a un dialogue entre les
deux assemblées alors en fait le
gouvernement qui a tardé tardé tarder
tarder à déposer son projet de loi
puisque on l'attendait de semaine en
semaine vous savez que on ne peut pas
examiner dans la première assemblée
saisie avant 6 semaines et donc c'est
pour échapper à cette contrainte que on
a joué de la procédure accélérée mais le
ça n'empêche pas effectivement comme si
elle est engagé le gouvernement à faire
deux lectures dans chaque assemblée
alors sans plus tarder direction à la
salle Clémenceau pour suivre les
premières auditions de cette commission
spéciale consacrée à la délimitation des
régions
donc comme nous comme la commission
spéciale a décidé donc nous poursuivons
les auditions auxquelles avait procédé
Michel Delbarre notre rapporteur la
semaine dernière à savoir le ministre de
l'intérieur de la décentralisation etc
je sais pas quoi encore bon et puis le
président de l'association des
présidents de région qui était dans
plusieurs et aujourd'hui on a le plaisir
d'accueillir le président de l'Assemblée
des départements de France
ainsi que Madame Marie-Françoise Pérol
Dumont vice-présidente et René Paul
Savary président de la commission
économique de l'Assemblée des
départements de France il est là et il
est un peu plus loin il aurait pu venir
là
parce qu'il fait partie de la délégation
de la DF il va
tant qu'on est encore autorisé accumuler
bien alors je rappelle que je rappelle
que la commission spéciale est saisie du
premier texte
du premier texte à savoir le projet de
loi relatif à la délimitation des
régions aux élections régionales et
départementales et modifiant le
calendrier électoral et comme chacun
sait ce texte est l'ensemble et la
partie d'un tout qui concerne aussi un
autre texte qui a été d'ailleurs délivré
en conseil des ministres le même jour ce
qui démontre bien qu'il y a une
continuité mais nous ne sommes pas
saisis pour l'instant
le Sénat est saisi mais la commission
spéciale n'est saisie que du texte sur
la délimitation des régions aux
élections régionales et départementales
et modifiant le calendrier électoral
monsieur le Président vous avez la
parole
ah bah non on va vous laisser faire un
exposé sur votre vision du projet et
puis ensuite bien entendu le rapporteur
et les collègues vous poseront toutes
les questions qui le souhaitent tout
cela dans un délai d'une heure très bien
si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs et également mes chers
collègues
mes chers collègues parlementaires qui
exercent une fonction de président
d'assemblée départementale je vois
qu'ils sont nombreux au sein de cette
commission spéciale
chargée oui
si je les saluais pas je serai impoli
monsieur le rapporteur
voilà c'est dommage d'ailleurs
voilà mais il est jamais trop tard
bien merci de nous recevoir pour cette
audition sur le premier texte concernant
la réforme de la carte électorale
les scrutins la date des élections et
autres et je suis accompagné par
Marie-Françoise Pérol Dumont présidente
du conseil général de Haute-Vienne et
René Paul Savary président du conseil
général de la Marne qui m'accompagne
pour cette audition d'abord sur la
modification de la carte régionale
nous aurons d'ailleurs je vous le dis
demain une assemblée générale ordinaire
de l'EDF qui était prévu ou à l'ordre du
jour il y aura les deux textes donc on
aura l'occasion d'en débattre et
certainement
d'essayer d'arrêter une position ce qui
fait que aujourd'hui je vais faire un
exercice un peu complexe mais d'essayer
de vous livrer notre point de vue où je
le dis d'emblée ira certainement une
partie d'un point de vue personnel
également sur le sujet d'abord c'est une
incompréhension non pas sur l'idée de
diminuer le nombre de régions mais c'est
d'essayer de comprendre quels sont les
critères objectifs qui ont présidé à se
redécoupage des régions de France
je le dis d'emblée et je crois que cette
approche est assez largement partagée
car aujourd'hui se préoccuper du nouvel
organisation des régions de France
c'est dans un exercice effectivement de
réorganisation territoriale de la
République mais c'est aussi avoir à
l'esprit de la relation des
collectivités à l'état et quelque part
en arrière-plan la conception que nous
avons de l'Europe et notamment de sa
construction politique pour aujourd'hui
pour demain je pense que tout cela est
consubstantiel et si l'on veut parler
quelque part d'une carte des régions
d'Europe puisque on sait que les régions
étant vraisemblablement consacré comme
étant celle qui aura la compétence du
développement économique et de l'emploi
ça renvoie là contestablement aux
relations avec les autres régions
d'Europe
en ayant le souci de faire attention aux
comparaison puisque d'un côté difficile
de comparer les régions de France au
Lander d'Allemagne puisque on est sur un
État fédéral en Allemagne en Autriche et
en Belgique qui sont les trois seules
États qui ont le statut de l'État
fédéraux et
l'Espagne dont on dit souvent à tort que
c'est un état quelque part fédéral qui
n'est pas le cas c'est un état à
autonomie régionale il est pas du tout
la même chose en matière de droit et
vous le savez bien les uns et les autres
donc aujourd'hui on est face à une carte
dont on a du mal à comprendre
les critères je l'ai dit à l'instant et
je pense qu'on aurait pu faire
différemment
moi je considère et quelques membres de
notre assemblée à ses nombreux pour
saluer les travaux de deux
parlementaires de votre Haute assemblée
qui avait fait notamment produit un
rapport de grande qualité je pense à
Jean-Pierre Raffarin et à Yves kratinger
qui ont fait un travail sur une nouvelle
organisation territoriale des régions et
qui est un travail en même temps
universitaire très scientifique mais
aussi très politique pour arriver si ma
mémoire est bonne à 8 grandes régions
qui avec des grandes fonctions
métropolitaine
d'aménagement du territoire qui combine
bien les espaces ruraux avec les espaces
urbains avec de grandes fonctions dans
le domaine de la santé de l'éducation de
la formation sur le plan économique même
s'il y avait quelques difficultés à
essayer de voir par rapport aux grandes
capitales régionales comment on pouvait
rechercher des complémentarités et en
sachant que c'est possible ou une
capitale peut avoir une fonction
administrative et politique et une autre
une fonction économique ça se voit dans
d'autres régions et je pense que c'est
des choses qui peuvent très bien se
gérer donc on arrive à cette situation
où le centre le Limousin est
Poitou-Charentes je vois bien les noms
qui sont derrière mais trouver là
quelque part une forme de cohérence
c'est quand même un peu compliqué
avec tout cela d'autres questions qui
sont posées dans quelques régions de
France et vous voyez à laquelle je pense
à la Bretagne je vois monsieur Dantec
qui est ici présent je lis si ce qu'ils
disent qu'il écrit et là il y a
effectivement des débats extrêmement
importants et sur la question
identitaire je me méfie un peu parce
qu'on sait ce que l'identité a porté
dans le passé j'ai pas envie que les
choses se reprennent ainsi qu'on est un
sentiment d'appartenance à un territoire
oui mais toutes les régions n'ont pas
quelque part une identité ou c'est un
sentiment d'appartenance à un territoire
qui justement a su accueillir faire
vivre altérité valeur républicaine
mais c'est de bien de cela dont il
s'agit avec à mon avis le découpage des
grandes des grandes régions
sur la nouvelle les effectifs des
conseils régionaux nous nous sommes
attentifs si vous voulez sur le sujet
selon lequel bon les assembler avec 150
membres pas plus mais de l'autre côté il
faut avoir un respect que les
départements qui restent parce que dans
ces deux textes de loi on a bien compris
que il s'agissait de la suppression à
terme du conseil départemental qui vient
puisque c'est toujours le Conseil
général c'est après les élections qu'on
aura le Conseil départemental c'était
dans la loi et l'espace géographique
d'action de l'Etat qui demeure et les
départements ne vont pas disparaître et
je pense d'ailleurs que quel que soit
les collectivités chez le Président je
me permets de vous dire s'il y a plus
d'assemblée c'est une collectivité
locale c'est pas parce que on en garde
une circonscription administrative de
l'État que le département
constitutionnellement demeure
c'est pour justement tu as le sens
supprimer le département collectivité
territoriale
c'est déjà l'essentiel donc je poursuis
mais c'est
ce que nous avions compris et c'est ce
que nous avons eu de cesse à la déesse
de plaider au président de la République
pour lui dire que on ne pourrait pas
faire quelque part et aller au bout de
la suppression des conseils généraux et
départements demain sont passés par la
Constitution et donc nous avons fini par
être rendu nous avions d'ailleurs
travaillé avec verpo et Rousseau et
d'ailleurs les avis étaient concordants
sur le sujet et d'ailleurs on l'a vu
dans la tribune ça a été repris au même
titre qu'il ne faut pas oublier non plus
l'arrêter du Conseil constitutionnel sur
la Corse avec le niveau substantiel de
compétences qu'on va avoir dans le
deuxième texte de loi nous savons bien
les uns les autres et qui nous
préservent quelque part momentanément de
l'avenir nous savons bien là les uns les
autres mais je reste sur le sujet
là en ce qui concerne le département
puisque on a vu qu'il y avait un minimum
de représentants des départements et je
pense qu'il faut qu'on soit très
soucieux non pas dans une approche
néo-ruraliste des espaces ruraux mais la
France elle est très diverses et on sait
quand même que aujourd'hui il y a une
ruralité qui est extrêmement vivante et
quand je vois les travaux des géographes
tels que le bras et autres qui montrent
qu'à la fin du siècle dernier il y a un
mouvement de décentralisation qui a
tendance à aller vers ces espaces là et
on voit une démographie qui est
dynamique y compris dans les
départements ruraux donc attention à ne
pas déséquilibrer la représentation
d'autant plus que vous savez bien les
uns les autres il y a un fort sentiment
d'abandon qui est exprimé dans ces
territoires et il n'est pas utile de
rappeler la carte électorale de ces
derniers mois par rapport à ces 10
territoires là donc moi je crois que
nous sommes là aussi il faudrait pas
demain qui est des régions de 150 et
dans lesquelles le poids des conseillers
régionaux de petits départements ne
soient pas à la hauteur par rapport
notamment au mont Dublin sans qu'on soit
dans une position caricaturale entre
larapage représentation des hommes et
des espaces je trouve qu'on peut trouver
quelque part une représentation assez
équitable des espaces et des territoires
et là-dessus nous ne serons extrêmement
attentifs j'observe que le texte ne
parle pas mon cher Christian Favier des
départements de la métropole parisienne
et pour autant
l'ADF nous portons là la défense de
l'institution départementale ou qu'elle
soit et puis sur les autres aspects il y
a un article qui dit que pour le
prochain scrutin des conseillers
départementaux et des conseillers
départemental le binôme que en cas de
bon je veux dire là-dessus il y a pas de
difficultés
la correction apportée au texte on
n'avait pas eu le temps continue la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel en
fait c'est ça c'est l'article
qui permet en cas de décès voilà parce
que le la loi avait dit ce que je
voulais dire là-dessus nous c'est
l'application de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel pour les prochaines j'en
profite pour dire oui oui ça pose pas de
problème d'accord
on est forcément toujours d'accord parce
que de toute façon ça s'impose
même si on n'est pas d'accord ça ne
change rien
et puis il y a effectivement parce que
les choses n'étaient pas dites jusqu'à
présent
je parle devant des experts vous le
savez bien
à partir du moment le Premier ministre
dans un discours parlé après le discours
du 8 avril de l'axe l'accélération
possible du calendrier on savait bien à
qui ça s'adressait et que il y a eu
l'idée à un moment donné de faire
disparaître le Conseil général beaucoup
plus tôt que prévu et là aussi on a
plaidé que si demain on veut faire des
transports de compétences parce que les
présidents les présidents de
départements comme d'autres élus
territoriaux sont des gens très
pratiques et que si demain on veut faire
un déménagement de compétences à
l'endroit d'autres collectivités il faut
bien quelqu'un fasse ce job et que
momentanément il y a encore besoin d'une
assemblée départementale
je pourrais dire d'autre chose sur le
texte qui viendra ensuite mais ce sera
l'objet d'une autre audition même si il
faut considérer il y a un lien entre les
deux quand même et puis je terminerai
avant de donner la deuxième texte
et
justement comme je vais terminer sur ce
point puis mes deux collègues je vais
leur laisser un peu le temps de
s'exprimer
à partir du moment où on a un découpage
régional
tel qu'il est proposé et d'ailleurs le
rapport gratiné Raffarin le précisait sa
justifiait encore plus je vais pas
parler forcément du département dans un
premier temps mais d'un niveau
intermédiaire entre les collectivités
locales et les grandes régions demain et
j'ai pu faire un travail avec la DF il y
a de ça quelques années je suis j'étais
auditionné devant vous à plusieurs
reprises je rappelle ces travaux
notamment à l'échelle de l'Europe ou
dans les six grands pays les plus
peuplés d'Europe il y a partout trois
niveaux de collectivité territoriale
c'est pas les fruits du hasard c'est sûr
qu'en ligne en Lituanie on va pas mettre
trois niveaux ça n'aurait pas de sens
mais chez nous c'est quand même le cas
et dans l'architecture du projet moi je
le comprends ainsi c'est que entre les
grandes régions et le niveau local tout
le monde sait qu'il y a besoin d'un
niveau intermédiaire et que la question
elle est posée entre le département
et les intercommunalités c'est ça la
réalité
d'où l'idée de faire grossir les
intercommunalités
si demain on doit faire en sorte qu'une
partie des compétences et des
départements aille vers d'autres niveaux
je crois qu'ils ne sont pas nombreux
c'est soit le conseil régional
soit à l'état
soit des collectivités intercommunales
et je vois bien les compétences de
départements bonjour quand il va falloir
transférer la PMI ou la protection de
l'enfance qui est la deuxième dépense
des départements et une grande partie du
bloc notamment du social et parce que
j'entends bien ce qui se dit finalement
le Conseil général par exemple sur les
trois allocations individuelles de
solidarité ne sont que des guichets sauf
que on oublie que à travers ces
allocations il y a toute une politique
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
pour certains il y a un gros travail qui
est fait sur les personnes âgées qui se
passent simplement que de verser des
allocations c'est d'être l'animateur de
toute l'environnement qui conduit au
Bien vieillir dans notre dans notre pays
et pour le handicap où nous sommes
considérés des experts sur le sujet mais
je m'arrêterai là pour l'instant
monsieur le Président pour laisser
Marie-Françoise et René Paul le soin de
compléter mon propos ou merci un point
de vue différent merci Monsieur
Président Madame Marie-Françoise Pérol
du que vous avez la parole
mesdames messieurs merci de nous
recevoir pour cette audition mon propos
va m'engager personnellement je crois
qu'il va aussi engager largement le
groupe majoritaire de l'ADF que j'ai
l'honneur de présider je voudrais
d'abord dire que nous sommes d'évidence
favorable au mouvement nous sommes pas
contre une évolution de notre
architecture territoriale dès lors
qu'elle s'inscrit dans un
approfondissement de la décentralisation
nous observons que depuis les années 80
tous les textes relatifs aux
collectivités territoriales sont tous
allés vers un approfondissement de la
décentralisation et de la démocratie
locale premier présupposé nous ne sommes
pas contre des évolutions
institutionnelles dès lors qu'elle
s'inscrivent dans l'intérêt des
populations que nous représentons
c'est la le deuxième a priori par
rapport à plutôt présupposé par rapport
à cette réforme premier point fusion des
régions fusion des régions pourquoi pas
des régions plus grandes pourquoi pas
mais pourquoi oui si on va vers de plus
grandes régions il faut d'abord définir
pourquoi quels sont les objectifs
quelles sont les compétences quelles
sont les moyens pour l'heure les régions
n'ont aucun levier fiscal elles sont
sous tutelle de dotation d'État donc si
on va vers de plus grandes régions quels
moyens va-t-on leur donner il me semble
que ces premiers par rapport à la
question des regroupements question des
compétences question des moyens donc
premièrement pour traiter les problèmes
de fond ensuite les problèmes de forme
par rapport au regroupement qui nous
sont proposés je crois que on peut dire
très clairement
tout en soutenant le gouvernement et
c'est mon cas par ailleurs que nous
sommes un peu surpris par la forme qui a
procédé regroupement qui nous sont
proposés il y a eu une première carte
qui est parue dans la presse le dimanche
et une autre carte le lundi annoncé par
le président de la République je crois
que lorsque l'on parle de regroupement
de région de fusion de région il faut
tenir compte des réalités territoriales
il faut tenir compte du vécu
de la de l'histoire du vécu culturel il
faut tenir compte des intérêts
économiques
élus d'un territoire
pauvre je pense que ce n'est pas en
regroupant des territoires à difficulté
l'addition de deux pauvres n'a jamais
fait un riche et donc il ne s'agit pas
de d'ajouter des handicaps donc je crois
qu'il faut tenir compte des bassins de
vie des intérêts économiques je crois
qu'il faut aussi qu'il y ait une
adhésion locale il me semble difficile
de proposer des regroupements de région
dès lors qu'il n'y a pas une adhésion
elle ne sera jamais à 100 pour 100% mais
nous voyons bien qu'il y a un élément
majoritaire je peux vous citer un
exemple région Limousin dans laquelle je
suis élu département de la Haute-Vienne
à l'évidence nous avons un tropisme avec
la façade atlantique et si grande région
il doit y avoir il nous semble que nos
habitudes culturelles et économiques et
bien plaide pour une grande région
Aquitaine Limousin Poitou-Charentes et
certainement pas pour une région avec le
Centre
j'observe d'ailleurs qu'on aura un petit
peu de difficultés à trouver quelle
serait la capitale de cette de cette
grande région là
s'il y a des grandes régions il faut a
fortiori président Le Breton vient de le
dire avant moi je vous allez voir
d'ailleurs que quel que soit nos
appartenances politiques les présidents
de conseil généraux ont une approche
assez semblable par rapport à ça s'il y
a des grandes régions il faut a fortiori
un niveau intermédiaire entre ces
grandes régions et le blog communal et
le bloc intercommunal alors on
l'appellera comme on veut on peut nous
débatiser on peut changer les noms mais
il faudra bien qu'il y ait une
collectivité de proximité qui assure la
proximité qui surtout assure la
péréquation le seul endroit où se
pratique la péréquation dans nos
départements c'est le Conseil Général
qui prend de la richesse dans les zones
urbaines productrices de richesse et qui
la redistribue sur des territoires qui
en ont moins il faudra bien qu'il y ait
ce niveau là pardon
merci
deuxième deuxième point par rapport au
premier transfert de compétences que
vous allez être amené à observer moi
j'ai tout à fait confiance dans le Sénat
et j'attends beaucoup de cette assemblée
en matière transfert de compétences
j'espère que vous n'allez pas commencer
le travail de décritable
qui signifie ré la fin des politiques de
proximité dont je viens de parler là
aussi les choses qui sont proposées ne
semblent pas très cohérentes proposer
les transports scolaires aux régions
vous savez dans un département un peu
montagneux comme le mien lorsqu'il y a
de la neige c'est très compliqué les
transports scolaires donc les gens
téléphonent et nous avons des antennes
du département un peu partout les gens
ont des personnes au bout du fil si elle
téléphone dans une grande région qui
serait Aquitaine Poitou-Charentes
Limousin elles auront une plateforme qui
sera à Bordeaux elles écouteront les
quatre saisons de Vivaldi et puis quand
les quatre saisons seront terminés on
leur dira appuyer sur la touche 1
revenez à la toucher toile etc je ne
suis pas sûr que ce soit la bonne façon
de procéder
un dernier point rapide même si ce n'est
pas le premier texte des communautés de
communes à 20000 il y a des endroits où
c'est souhaitable il y a des
départements où c'est souhaitables
l'évolution de la carte intercommunale
était une nécessité il y a des endroits
où ça n'est pas possible dans certains
départements ruraux à faible densité de
population imaginez des communautés de
communes à vanille cela me semble
porteur de gros risques pour la
démocratie et pour le vivre ensemble je
voudrais dire aussi qu'à travers tout ça
il me semble on était en train
d'inverser la charge de la preuve
jusqu'à présent
le fait communautaire les communautés de
communes elles sont le prolongement du
fait communal et non pas l'inverse il ne
faudrait pas inverser la donne j'ai
toute confiance sur la sagesse
sénatoriale pour intégrer ces choses là
je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente alors menée
monsieur René Paul Savary
ben écoutez moi aujourd'hui en tant que
représentant des Présidents de Conseils
généraux
et du centre je ne peux qu'approuver les
propos de ma collègue du groupe
socialiste en étant beaucoup plus modéré
par rapport aux critiques faits envers
le gouvernement parce que je ne voudrais
pas que mes propos soient des propos
d'opposition simplement je crois que on
peut partager nous sommes en accord pour
être en mouvement preuve en est c'est
que nous avions proposé nous une
organisation horizontale avec un
conseiller territorial qui était en
charge des actions de proximité des
départements amortisseurs sociales et
aménageurs du territoire et qui se
réunissait pour les compétences
régionales stratégiques bien définie
donc nous étions sur un positionnement
précis qui n'a pas été accepté qui a été
combattu par la majorité actuelle dont
acte aujourd'hui la proposition c'est
plutôt une organisation horizontale
c'est-à-dire des très grandes régions
mais derrière
automatiquement elle impose cette notion
horizontale de très grande région avoir
une structure de proximité donc je veux
dénoncer au nom de mon collègues me
semble-t-il et de façon largement
unanime l'incohérence du schéma proposé
parce que s'il y a pas l'échelon de
proximité intermédiaire le schéma ne
peut pas tenir et cela a été exprimé à
travers les propos de de madame Dumont
alors rappelez par rapport à la carte
territoriale
proposé pour la découpe régionale ben
écoutez je prendrai qu'un exemple
l'exemple Picardie Champagne-Ardenne ou
les régions sud de la Haute-Marne je
vais pas citer la Marne dont on a un
représentant ici par exemple sénateur
gainé se retrouvera à pratiquement à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres près
aussi près de la baie de Somme Picardie
que de Marseille donc que vous proposiez
un rattachement de la Haute-Marne à la
Baie de Somme ou bien à la région du Sud
reviendra dans la territorialité au même
au même phénomène donc il va aller voir
où à Marseille ou à Amiens comment on
refera la traverse de sa commune la
traverse départementale si on transfère
une partie des compétences
départementales notamment les routes
départementales ou les collèges qui bien
sûr seront la priorité de cette grande
région comment ils seront réalisés donc
on voit bien que là il y a un problème
de répartition des compétences qu'il a
aussi n'est pas cohérent je voulais le
souligner rappelez également que se
posera et ça n'a échappé à personne le
problème des départements chef-lieu de
région il y en avait 22 aujourd'hui qui
avait une préfecture de région un hôtel
du département un hôtel de région il y
en aura plus que 14 demain donc il y en
a 8 qui vont perdre énormément par
rapport à cette réforme et qui sont
souvent les plus petits et qui va mettre
en danger toute l'économie locale de
ville je citerai en ce qui me concerne
Châlons-en-Champagne qui perdant toute
la caractéristique administrative va se
dépeupler complètement donc c'est
quelque chose qu'il faudra prendre en
compte parce que s'il y a pas des
mouvements de personnel derrière ça veut
dire qu'il y a aucune intérêt à faire
une organisation territoriale maintenant
je voudrais souligner simplement en
complément le rôle d'expertise et de
mutualisation des départements nous ne
sommes pas des simples guichets
distributions d'aide sociale je prendrai
des exemples il y a des départements un
taux de couverture pour la petite
enfance bien supérieure à la moyenne
nationale parce qu'ils ont mené une
véritable politique dans ce domaine là
d'autres ont d'autres spécificités donc
cette mutualisation et cette capacité
d'exercice acquise avec 20 ou 30 ans de
décentralisation n'est pas au jour
d'aujourd'hui transférable pourquoi
parce que les intercommunalités n'y sont
pas prêtes et des intercommunalités à
20000 chez moi ça va se traduire dans
les zones à 7 habitants au kilomètre
carré sachant que la moyenne de ce
département est de 52 habitants
kilomètre carré par une interco qui va
partir 25% de mon territoire donc dans
la cette réforme intercommunale il va y
avoir 5 6 intercommunalités qui
prendront des compétences qui
deviendront 5 petits départements sans
la taille critique pour exercer les
responsabilités donc transformer un
département mutualisateur avec une
capacité d'exercice en 5 6 petits
départements critiques n'est pas d'une
redoutable évidence quand on concept
pour améliorer le service rendu à notre
population et trouver des économies
voilà ce que je voulais dire les
intercommunalités ont en plus très peu
très rarement la compétence sociale et
que c'est bien de social qu'il s'agit
qu'il faudra transférer et même les
agglomérations n'ont pas la compétence
sociale donc il faudra déjà acquérir
cette compétence entrer dans la culture
et puis ensuite transférer un
savoir-faire donc il y a un certain
nombre de difficultés qu'il faut
appréhender qu'il faut appréhender pour
voir comment on peut éventuellement les
traiter voilà je vous remercie et
monsieur le Président alors monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la parole d'abord
si vous avez pas de question en
particulier le président mais j'ai
écouté avec attention ce qui ce qui
vient d'être dit bon on a eu une
illustration
et défense du rôle du département
j'ai bien entendu mais c'est pas l'objet
de la loi
à laquelle on est confronté puisque cet
objet a d'abord
pour
nécessiter de créer de nouvelles régions
et il ne concerne directement le
département
peut-être que si des départements
veulent prendre une option de changer
de région
la loi on en est là
alors je comprends que la loi sur les
compétences
va beaucoup plus concerner effectivement
la répartition entre les compétences
régionales et départementales puisqu'on
aura se prononcer sur des compétences
régionales c'est là où on retrouvera
effectivement des des préoccupations
voilà tout ce que je peux dire je vois
pas dans ce que nous allons débattre à
propos de la première loi en quoi nous
mettons en cause j'allais dire les les
bienfaits l'utilité et les
responsabilités du département tel que
vous l'avez présenté bien lire
quand tu me parles de l'aide sociale au
niveau des intercommunalités moi je suis
dans la seconde doit et bien d'accord
c'est pas dans la première comportera
c'est vrai c'est la raison pour laquelle
les deux vont intervenir
le président Le Breton incité en France
en
cité quand même le rapport gratiné
Raffarin aura fait un gratiné qui disait
bien oui à des grandes régions ils
allaient même plus loin que le
gouvernement puisque ça peut être 8 10
régions mais à condition à condition
qu'on garde un méchant de proximité qui
pour les les auteurs unanimes de l'arrêt
de la de la commission était le
département bon c'est quand même bon
stade où nous en sommes on peut toujours
aller vers 8 ou 10 grandes régions moi
je suis d'accord
puis après oui comme vous oui bien sûr
ça peut ça peut d'ailleurs peut-être si
on fait vite ou discret grande région ça
va pouvoir certainement faciliter
l'élaboration de la carte
bon alors j'ai désinscrits j'ai monsieur
Doliger et Monsieur Retailleau président
mes armes Monsieur Le Cam monsieur
longuet
je vous rappelle que nous avons jusqu'à
17h
je vous incite quand même à essayer de
poser des questions aux
invités
ce qui ne vous empêche pas de donner
votre avis j'en suis convaincu de toute
façon je ne peux pas vous empêcher bon
alors
Monsieur Doliger
les choses à l'envers et qui a une
grande hypocrisie dans la manière dont
on traite les textes puisque on traite
d'avoir du découpage avant de traiter
des compétences mais bon c'est la seule
réflexion que je ferai non mais
simplement je voulais poser des
questions au président de l'adnf nous
avons nous la semaine prochaine on nous
propose de voter une carte à 14 régions
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut qu'on
la vote en l'état et que c'est une bonne
carte intelligente et qui respecte les
territoires donc pensez qu'il faut qu'on
la vote oui ou non
est-ce que vous pensez qu'en huit jours
on est en capacité de redéfinir une
autre carte donc est-ce que le délai
qu'on nous donne de huit jours pour
partir d'aujourd'hui pour redessiner une
autre carte à 8 10 12 14 régions 15 mais
est une bonne chose et troisièmement
est-ce que vous pensez qu'éventuellement
la carte des régions pourrait être
modifier en sortant des départements de
certaines régions quand on ne se
limitant plus à l'espace purement
régional donc en modifiant l'article 1
et dans lequel il est dit qu'on ne peut
respecter que les limites régionales
éventuellement et ce qu'on peut
respecter les limites départementales
simplement le dernier point est-ce que
vous pensez alors c'est plus dans le
deuxième texte mais que
l'interco pourrait se substituer au
département tel que l'on enfin dans les
compétences départementales pour
certaines telles que l'on définit
aujourd'hui l'intercos c'est à dire que
ça voudrait dire que l'on reconnaît à ce
moment-là la suppression des
départements donc êtes-vous pour la
suppression des départements
Bruno Retailleau
sont des questions qui vous sont des
questions qui s'adressent aussi à
Claudie Lebreton bien sûr je ne suis pas
d'accord avec le rapporteur le texte que
nous allons avoir et la partie d'un tout
on verra d'ailleurs bien si le Conseil
constitutionnel considère que les textes
sont liés ou pas ça sera intéressant
mais on doit avoir une vision d'ensemble
c'est évident
le pouvoir voudrait que on saucissonne
les choses bien mais on souhaite nous
les parlementaires les sénateurs avoir
une vision globale ma première question
monsieur le Président de l'ADF vous vous
êtes engagé puisque c'est au nom de
soi-disant gaspillage d'efficacité
d'économie vous êtes engagé à
réactualiser une étude d'impact en
matière d'économie sur la disparition
des départements où est-ce qu'on est
cette réactualisation puisqu'une étude
avait été faite en 2009
voilà alors à l'époque effectivement
c'est un autre gouvernement mais
qu'est-ce qu'il en est de cette étude
d'abord et puis deuxième question
je ne comprends pas l'idée de la
dilution du département
en confiance transférant des compétences
aux intercommunalités finalement ce sera
un émiettement de la compétence sociale
ça ira finalement à l'opposé d'une
mutualisation qu'on voudrait par
ailleurs nous imposer avec des grandes
régions donc il y a une contradiction je
trouve parfaite avec une parcellisation
un émiettement des politiques sociales à
l'intérieur même de nos territoires bon
qui me semble-t-il cadre mal avec les
principes que proclament le texte ma
question elle est aussi c'est le cas
posée rigoler parce que vous avez été
extrêmement subtil dans votre façon
d'aborder les choses je pose la question
président de l'ADF est-ce que la
disparition des départements vous va
bien ou pas est-ce que les compétences
massives c'est à dire la dévitalisation
avant leur disparition vous va bien
merci monsieur le Président moi j'aurai
une première question monsieur le
Président de la DF
est-ce qu'il quelle est sa position par
rapport à la possibilité pour les
conseils généraux de donner un avis sur
le rattachement de leur département à
une autre région que celle qui est
prévue
s'il y a des amendements ce sont est-ce
que ça correspond à votre position
deuxièmement
on rebondissant sur les propos du
rapporteur je considère avec tout
l'amitié et le respect que j'ai pour lui
que nous dire que les deux textes n'ont
rien à voir c'est quand même une
imposture je le dis très clairement
parce que c'est ce que je pense bon et
on se demande pourquoi et d'ailleurs
c'est une deuxième question à monsieur
le Président de la DF êtes-vous
favorable au report des élections
départementales parce que si les deux
textes sont totalement indépendants
c'est une bonne question de savoir si il
est justifié de perdre du temps et de
faire voter nos concitoyens en plein
hiver dans nos départements où les
routes sont difficiles
bon
et puis et puis très simplement monsieur
le Président de l'ADF j'ai pas bien
compris si vous étiez quel était votre
position personnelle sur la suppression
des conseils généraux et dans un premier
temps sur la dévitalisation de ces
conseils généraux et je souhaiterais
simplement une réponse claire êtes-vous
pour ou à vous contre
merci Monsieur Mezard Monsieur Le Cam
c'est le président
il est évident comme le rappeler Bruno
Retailleau à l'instant que les deux
textes sont un tout ont-ils pour
objectif d'aller à moyen terme vers un
état fédéral et comme second objectif ou
le transfert de la dette de l'État vers
les collectivités locales moi si je
partage l'opinion du Président de la DF
concernant son opposition au vidage du
contenu des départements je constate que
les deux dans l'ensemble de textes on va
donner beaucoup plus de pouvoir aux
régions beaucoup de plus de pouvoir aux
communautés de communes là-dessus
d'ailleurs je partage la vie de Madame
Pérol Dumont qui a bien montré que les
comités de communes sont en train de
prendre le pas sur les communes essayer
de convaincre vos collègues de cette
prise de conscience si on tient compte
de l'affaiblissement qui est prévu des
compétences des communes moi je voudrais
savoir si vous partagez ma vision des
choses qui consiste à avoir demain une
vision verticale de la politique de
l'État qui est contraire à l'esprit de
décentralisation des années 80 cette
vision verticale du haut vers le bas qui
va s'appliquer à mon avis est une vision
particulièrement anti-démocratique de la
conception de la politique et c'est pas
sans doute cela qui va rapprocher le
citoyen du politique demain là c'est le
fond de la question merci
merci
Monsieur Gérard Longuet oui merci
monsieur le Président ma question
évidemment s'adresse à Claudie Lebreton
l'élu locale a une particularité c'est
qu'il représente des habitants sur un
territoire et je voulais connaître la
position de du président de l'adnf sur
la représentativité des élus
départementaux et régionaux et quelle
marge de manœuvre
accepterait-il et considère-t-il que les
positions du Conseil constitutionnel
sont totalement
pertinentes pour restituer la vie locale
au regard de l'obligation d'une
représentativité moyenne qui ne permet
pas de restituer la singularité des
territoires vous avez évoqué dans votre
souhait préliminaire des assemblées à
représentants c'est dans le texte et
vous vous acceptez ce principe le
croyez-vous compatible avec la
représentation des territoires effectifs
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais poser une question qui est une
sorte d'encouragement à la DF et à son
président à entrer en résistance en
précisant en précisant leur pensée même
si je comprends que Monsieur Le Breton
était tenu aujourd'hui à une sorte de
devoir de réserve mais au fond il pourra
nous faire une réponse personnelle
puisqu'il a ses convictions sur le sujet
et nous serons heureux de l'entendre
moi je crois que cette réforme dans son
double aspect est une vraie rupture
jusqu'à présent toutes les lois
successives étaient inspirées en matière
de liberté locale par la
décentralisation c'est-à-dire le
transfert de compétences de l'État aux
collectivité territoriales et par la
recherche d'une mutualisation avec le
développement de la terre communalité ça
allait dans ce sens je ne connais pas de
loi qui depuis 1982 ne soit pas allé
dans ce sens est-ce que vous n'avez pas
le sentiment
monsieur le Président que on est en
train de faire exactement le contraire
c'est à dire d'une part la
recentralisation des compétences de
proximité exercée par les départements
en faveur cette fois non pas de l'État
mais des régions mais pas des régions
actuelles en faveur d'hyper région
recentralisation d'un côté et puis
peut-être des mutualisations de l'autre
parce que le département c'est quand
même le lieu de la mutualisation le lieu
aussi de la garantie de l'égalité des
droits et quand on prétend démembrer les
départements en faveur des
intercommunalités mais on assure plus la
mutualisation aux multiplie les dépenses
pour l'exercice d'une même compétence au
niveau intercommunal et puis on a
surplus l'égalité des droits est-ce que
vous partagez ce point de vue et si oui
qu'attendez-vous peut-être vous attendez
demain pour entrer en résistance
merci alors Benoît Huret oui
beaucoup de points ont été exprimés et
il y en a un autre moi qui me préoccupe
c'est la façon dont on engage se débat
la précipitation
l'urgence n'est pas là et écoutons un
peu nos concitoyens et après on
s'étonnera de leur
désintérêt pour la chose publique et en
plus la façon dont on aborde
quand même monsieur le rapporteur
il serait plus honnête et plus
responsable de commencer à parler des
compétences et de le faire de manière
apaisée des complémentarités entre les
collectivités que d'agiter un chiffon
rouge entre élus sur la périphérie de
telle ou telle région
et en plus autre question de fond et
c'est pour ça que le débat sur les
compétences est important
quelle mission confie-t-on aux régions
quelles compétences quels moyens
et quel poids des régions à côté de
l'État et la capacité qu'aura la France
qui n'est pas un État fédéral de parler
d'une seule voix demain à Bruxelles ou
dans les autres instances
internationales aura-t-elle avec elle
l'autorité française le président de la
République son gouvernement
des responsables de régions qui seront
un peu des fédérateurs des
coordonnateurs ou des barons avec leur
spécificités leur diversité cette
question est importante au moment où
l'Europe doit se doter de politique plus
forte plus intégrée pour que ce
continent européen continue d'exister
dans le concert de la mondialisation là
où les pouvoirs les développements sont
en train de se prendre
et quand on est parlementaires on doit
avoir cette vision là avant de se
disputer sur tel ou telle périphérie
alors quand vous êtes dans un
département à l'est vous êtes plus
attiré vers une vers une une nouvelle
région dans un à l'ouest mais c'est du
délire ça c'est accessoire par rapport
au fond nous avons ce devoir de
parlementaire et d'exiger un travail
sérieux et ne pas continuer à travailler
de cette façon là car le Parlement va
être une nouvelle fois discrédité
merci Benoît alors Monsieur Le Dantec
oui quand on lit la loi la loi de
Marylise le branchu le département n'a
pas disparu loin sans faut
originellement il y en avait un c'est
pour ça que je ne corrige pas c'est bien
hardantec en breton donc ça colle
parfaitement donc l'article avait bien
disparaît merci donc quand on lit la loi
finalement pour l'instant le département
est loin d'avoir disparu il a toujours
la totalité de l'action sociale la loi
précise bien que c'est lui qui doit
assurer la garantie d'accès aux services
publics c'est ce que j'ai lu dans la loi
et si effectivement la loi dit qu'il
faudrait engager un débat serein pour sa
disparition échéance de 2020 ça n'est
pas dans la loi c'est-à-dire le temps du
débat serein sur la disparition du
département et dans un temps semi
incertain donc la question que je me
pose aujourd'hui puisque nous avons un
débat sur le renforcement de la région
dans comme collectivité de planification
et développement économique c'est ça le
cœur de la de la de la réforme et donc
il faut peut-être pas crier quand on
quand on n'a pas obligatoirement aussi
mal que ça donc moi ma question un peu
paradox serait de dire est-ce que cette
réforme ne permet pas au final au
département de trouver une nouvelle
légitimité
puisque il y a bien cette idée qu'entre
les petites intercos et de très grandes
régions il y a peut-être un espace qui
reste à
accaparé à investir et notamment est-ce
que la réflexion ne doit pas aussi être
mener sur des départements qui
correspondraient à des territoires vécus
qui ne sont pas obligatoirement la
circonscription administrative de 1789
et que finalement plutôt que d'être dans
une vision défensive que j'entends
beaucoup ici pas obligatoirement de la
part des représentants de l'ADF est-ce
qu'il y a pas une nouvelle réflexion à
mener sur ce département peut-être plus
grand ou peut-être plus petit ça dépend
des territoires qui correspondrait à la
réalité d'un certain nombre de
territoires vécus et qui serait
l'échelon nécessaire garantissant le
service public gardant l'action sociale
entre des grandes régions dédiées au
développement économique et des
intercommunalités parce que cette loi
n'est pas tant n'est pas une loi sera
disparition du département cette loi est
une loi sur le fait d'éclaircir les
compétences des uns et des autres et
donc je voudrais vous entendre là-dessus
merci Monsieur Dantec dernier orateur
inscrit philippe Adnot je vous remercie
monsieur le Président de répondre
on a tous dit que la nécessité d'une
vision globale s'impose à nous le
rapporteur pour autant à lui reprit le
texte c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on a
traité
d'un texte qui fait des partages pour
autant
on peut revenir au fondamentaux
tout ceci nous est présenté parce qu'on
prétend que il faut
réformer la France pour faire des
économies
et donc ma première observation et
celle-ci qu'en est-il des économies
potentielles
allons-nous avoir une analyse de la Cour
des comptes
quelle contribution l'ADF va-t-elle
faire pour montrer qu'en place
d'économie il va y avoir des surcos
colossaux parce que la vérité c'est
celle-là il n'y aura pas d'économie et
il y aura au contraire une
multiplication de la dépense publique et
on peut prendre tous les exemples qu'on
veut pour le déterminer si quelqu'un ici
est capable de nous dire comment on va
faire des économies moi je le mets au
défi de l'argumenter concrètement et je
pourrais personnellement argumenter dans
l'autre sens en montrant tout ce qui va
provoquer une explosion de la dépense
alors
il paraît qu'il faut supprimer des
strates et bien nous nous sommes dans
une région Champagne-Ardenne ou en ce
moment la région impose pour distribuer
les fonds du fédère que les communautés
de communes créent une nouvelle strate
non non c'est pas le pays le pays n'est
pas habilité les Petr et donc on est
aujourd'hui avec une que veut dire PED
il va vous le dire
territoriaux
ce qui est d'abord monsieur le Président
et j'en profite pour le dire ici et pour
que à un moment donné quelqu'un puisse
nous donner des réponses ce qui est
totalement illégal par rapport à la
constitution c'est-à-dire que la
Constitution interdit à une collectivité
pour distribuer ses subventions
et les subventions de l'Europe encore
plus de conditionner l'octroi de ses
aides à de nouvelles à des nouvelles
obligations qui ne sont pas légales
aujourd'hui dans la région
Champagne-Ardenne le président de Région
dit aux collectivités si vous voulez
avoir les fonds de l'Europe vous devrez
créer une structure supplémentaire cette
structure supplémentaire ne pourra pas
être l'addition de communauté de
communes elle devra regrouper beaucoup
plus large et il devrait y avoir
nécessairement embauche de
fonctionnaires supplémentaires
donc j'attire votre attention sur le
délire qu'on est en train de constater
au moment où on nous dit il faut
diminuer le nombre de strates nous avons
des gens qui imposent la constitution de
nouvelles strates et des nouvelles
dépenses de fonctionnement j'attire
votre attention là-dessus parce que
c'est quand même me semble-t-il
relativement grave et
anticonstitutionnel donc je pose la
question
qu'allons-nous faire collectivement pour
empêcher cette action qui est totalement
illégitime
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est que il faut s'élever
vigoureusement contre l'idée absurde que
demain des intercommunalités qu'elles
soient de 20000 de 30000 ou de 40 000
habitants pourrait remplacer l'action de
département
je vais prendre un exemple en ce moment
qui s'occupe de la montée en débit
ce sont les départements
demain
non mais demain qui va s'occuper de la
montée en débit
qui est-ce que la Fédération des
intercommunalités va être capable de
dégager les 40 50 60 millions d'euros
par département que nous sommes en train
d'investir pour arriver à réaliser la
montée en débit avec des plans sur
plusieurs années que l'État nous impose
c'est l'État qui nous l'impose en même
temps il veut nous supprimer et qui va
s'en occuper et les régions ne financent
pas les régions disent à si on veut
faire la montée en débit on va utiliser
l'argent de l'Europe mais on y met pas
notre propre argent on en a pas et donc
je cette illustration montre bien que
l'élément déterminant de l'équilibre des
territoires c'est la présence à côté des
régions de départements mais c'est pas
l'objet de notre texte aujourd'hui
l'objet de notre texte aujourd'hui c'est
de décrypter les anomalies dans ce qui
nous est proposé je vais essayer d'en
décrypter une
alors qu'on dit il faut agrandir les
régions on maintient la région
Nord-Pas-de-Calais à deux départements
alors même qu'il va y avoir une
métropole qui va se constituer à Lille
alors racontez-moi est-ce que quelqu'un
dans cette assemblée peut me dire le
rôle qui va continuer à être dévolu à la
région Nord-Pas-de-Calais quand l'île
aura repris les compétences des
départements en matière sociale repris
les compétences de la région en matière
économique dans une région à deux
départements quel sera le rôle du
Conseil régional et donc je dis très
clairement le découpage qui nous a été
proposé alors même que moi je peux
comprendre qu'on veuille agrandir les
régions très clairement il faut le dire
la région Nord-Pas-de-Calais à deux
départements est une anomalie criante et
ils doivent au contraire avoir la
Picardie et à ce moment-là la région
continuera d'exister avec un rôle malgré
la présence d'une métropole lilloise qui
aura absorbé toutes les autres
compétences
quel est le vote question monsieur Adnot
vous avez bien compris monsieur le
Président que ma première question c'est
est-ce que on va procéder à une analyse
des coûts de ce texte de manière à faire
le lit la litière de ces de tous ces
litières
de tous ces pseudo spécialiste qui
interviennent à longueur de journée dans
les médias pour dire que on va faire 17
milliards 30 milliards d'économies etc
etc nous savons tous que c'est faux et
en plus on nous annonce que s'agissant
des pompiers on va éventuellement les
renationsaliser ah oui mais c'est pas
indépendant
monsieur j'imagine que par exemple si
demain les pompiers sont régionalisés je
peux vous garantir qu'il faudra des
généraux pour commander les colonels
dans les départements et que là en
termes d'économie vous allez faire la
totale donc je comprends monsieur le
Président que vous me demandez de
m'arrêter mais j'aurais aimé que le
président de la déesse soit plus
combattif il est censé nous défendre il
est censé montrer que ce texte est une
atteinte à nos territoires demain les
territoires ruraux avec ce texte n'ont
plus de défenseur non plus d'aménageurs
on va dire au département qu'ils n'ont
plus le droit de faire d'aménagement
rural c'est quand même une originalité
particulièrement
intéressante et donc il faut le dire
très clairement ce texte est un mensonge
un mensonge sur les économies qu'on va
faire un mensonge sur la capacité des
territoires à continuer à exister et
donc il nous faut le combattre
vigoureusement
très brièvement c'est pour dire que
comme j'ai eu l'avantage dans ma vie
passée d'être
à la commission des lois à 1981 quant à
eu lieu le débat sur la décentralisation
j'entends 33 ans plus tard les mêmes
arguments
prononcés par des collègues différents
sur la décentralisation ce qui me
rassure sur le débat et je pense que
nous pourrons avancer voilà l'histoire
est béguée par elle se répète monsieur
le président
et de ce commentaire alors le président
Le Breton après toutes ces questions ces
professions de foi enfin il y a tout
dans les dans les les propos de nos
collègues mais on vous a interpellé
personnellement sur un certain nombre de
sujets en disant que pensez-vous puisque
vous ne savez pas encore ce que pense
votre assemblée ça sera demain si j'ai
bien compris donc vous pouvez vous
exprimer comment
un petit idée monsieur le Président à
vous la parole merci monsieur le
président
c'est Philippe Bas
qui m'a invité à entrer en résistance
faut-il prendre le maquis
bien et puis je parle
il y a un public ici nombreux
de toute sensibilité politique
et aujourd'hui dans ma famille
je n'ai pas que des louanges ou des
soutiens
loin de là
parce que je suis un homme libre
et je considère que sur des sujets aussi
importants que l'organisation
territoriale de la République
qui peut bouleverser des années et des
années d'organisation parce que tout
cela ça vient de loin ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il ne faille pas changer les
choses
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faille pas
réformer
nos organisations et de regarder comment
on peut répondre à la question qui n'a
pas été évoquée de la démocratie locale
de l'exercice des responsabilités de
l'esprit originel des lois de 80 qui
sont proprement restés intemporels nous
savons bien les uns et les autres et je
mesure aussi le fait que cette loi est
ces réformes
se font dans les pires des conditions
sur le plan économique et social
je pense que si les lois
décentralisation avaient été votée comme
en 82 dans les 100 premiers jours
suite été plus facile
car à partir du moment où on a pris
quelques retards les groupes de pression
se sont mis en marche et il a été
extrêmement difficile de trouver quelque
part le bon compromis même si il y a eu
quelque part des avancées alors j'en
viens aux questions précises qui ont été
posées par Jacques mesard et quelques
autres sur la carte lorsque nous nous
avons parlé à plusieurs voix sur la
porteur vous avez pu observer que
j'étais resté sur la carte des régions
puisque c'était l'objectif même si je
considère comme beaucoup de membres de
cette Haute Assemblée qu'on ne peut pas
dire qu'il n'y a pas un lien avec le
deuxième texte car réorganisation des
régions compétences qui viendront après
moyens financiers c'est intimement lié
et même moi je suis allé plus loin
jusqu'à parler de l'Europe
et de la conception que nous avons de
l'Europe par rapport à l'organisation
territoriale de la République et à la
réforme de l'État qui dans la tribune du
président de la République il n'y a que
deux lignes sur le sujet
alors qu'à mon avis c'est la question
essentielle
car on le voit bien à travers les
sondages qui sont réalisés aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qui est observé c'est
qu'il y a une véritable confiance de nos
concitoyens dans les services publics
territoriaux moins du côté de l'État
et je veux dire il y a pas photo 84 %
pour les uns quand c'est plus qu'à 52%
pour les administrations d'État ça veut
dire que nous avons apporté la preuve
depuis plus de 30 ans à la tête de nos
collectivités territoriales de notre
efficience même si quelquefois on nous
fait des procès d'intention qui ne sont
pas justes et nous savons bien les uns
et les autres alors sur la carte de la
région des régions de France j'ai donné
mon point de vue
j'ai trouvé que les conclusions des
rapports du rapport gratin g et Raffarin
était plutôt excellent sur le sujet
maintenant c'est vous les parlementaires
c'est pas moi
l'ADF lorsqu'elle propose elle ne peut
pas proposer normalement elle cherche
toujours si les parlementaires sont
d'accord avec des propositions que nous
sommes amenés à faire et de dire il les
font l'heure c'est comme ça que les
choses fonctionnent normalement et sur
cette carte là je sais que il y a
plusieurs responsables de départements
qui voudraient d'ailleurs que on puisse
ouvrir quelque part la carte à quelques
améliorations surtout dans des
départements qui sont à la limite de
région je pense aux Charentes par
exemple qui sont intéressés plutôt
d'aller vers la Gironde je pense que là
aussi et quand on connaît ces
territoires là ça me paraît tout à fait
pertinent
votre collègue Président du Conseil
Général de l'Oise qui dit est-ce que la
place
gauloise est toujours dans la Picardie
alors qu'on sait que le l'Oise est dans
l'orbite de la de la région parisienne
et on pourrait délimiter et je pourrais
même parler monsieur Dantec de la
Loire-Atlantique voilà qui est en
Bretagne pose un certain nombre de
questions pour d'autres raisons que l'on
peut observer ailleurs et là aussi il
manque dans la loi le fait que on ne
demande pas la vie des collectivités
territoriales qui sont dans les régions
et notamment les départements ou voir
d'autres collectivités ce qui me serait
assez pertinents bon on le fait assez
fréquemment sur d'autres d'autres sujets
donc moi personnellement je pense que il
faudrait qu'il y ait un découpage un peu
plus précis et qui permettrait peut-être
sur certaines cartes de revoir
l'économie générale du projet en pouvant
rebattre les cartes pour un certain
nombre de départements puisque cette
question là qui était posée tout à
l'heure le deuxième point
concernant les aspects
Jacques mesard dit êtes-vous d'accord
avec le report des élections
départementales on a cru à un moment
donné il y avait pas y en avoir
puisque l'idée était de supprimer le
département au 1er janvier 2016 dans le
compter heureux de constater que
aujourd'hui il y a de nouveau des
élections départementales qui sont
annoncées en décembre
2015 avec les élections régionales nous
je pense que nous sommes favorables à ce
qu'il y ait des élections
départementales pour qu'il y ait
notamment un département par contre nous
sommes hostiles et plus que réservé
suite des transferts de compétences des
départements vers d'autres collectivités
territoriales on s'interroge non mais la
question il l'a posé
parce qu'après je le connais un petit
peu il dira le président n'a pas répondu
à la question de présence qu'il a
répondu non je le dis je le dis donc je
préfère nous nous sommes pas hostiles et
c'est bien qu'il y ait des élections
départementales viendront le temps de la
question des collèges des transports etc
et on trouve que nous les collèges sont
plus des établissements la République de
proximité
très proche des écoles alimentaires et
maternelles et que le lycée est plutôt
déjà dans l'enseignement supérieur et
que c'était une bonne découpure non mais
ce Sidot on n'a pas débattu donc on m'a
autorisé tout à l'heure à donner mon
point de vue donc je le donne je suis
invité voilà le faire j'ai toujours
relativisé les choses ce qui veut dire
qu'à la question dévitalisation des
départements je suis pas d'accord
et là le dessus
il n'y a pas de il y a pas de d'état
d'âme et d'ailleurs il Françoise Pérol
Dumont il y a la rappeler tout à l'heure
sur les aspects financiers j'ai déjà dit
et je pense que j'ai été le premier
publiquement
à demander au prix de la République et
au Premier ministre
de demander à Didier Migaud le premier
président de la Cour des comptes de
faire une étude très précise si on
supprimant des niveaux on fera des
économies de dépenses je pense que tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire il y a
une grande crédibilité et confiance dans
la cour des comptes on n'a pas toujours
été d'accord sur tout mais quand même
sur l'estomment majorité quand j'ai
rencontré le président de la République
il a trouvé que l'idée était plutôt
pertinente j'ai même eu une ministre qui
m'a dit que oui ils allaient donner
droit à cette demande pour l'instant
rien c'est pour cela que à Bruno
Retailleau mais je crois que tu ne l'est
plus là mais vous lui vous lui redirez
tout à l'heure que sur les études qui
ont été faites par la DF en 2009 si
l'homme et marais bonne nous avons
demandé au cabinet qu'il l'avait fait de
réactualiser avec le concours d'un autre
notamment de savoir si effectivement ça
faisait des économies mais je pense que
la meilleure initiative et de solliciter
la Cour des comptes et que la Cour des
comptes fasse ce travail là et comme ça
parce que ça ça permettra de faire taire
un certain nombre de médias
qui d'ailleurs ne travaille pas à fond
ce sujet extrêmement compliqué et qui
comme ça je veux dire écrivent et disent
des choses qui sont totalement fausses
en restant sur la superficialité des
questions importantes auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés et c'est quelquefois
parfaitement insupportable le troisième
élément il y a une question qui a été
posée sur les intercommunalités sur le
niveau intermédiaire
la France est le seul pays d'Europe qui
n'a pas voulu faire la fusion de ces
communes alors que avant d'être à 28 la
France était le pays qui avait 50% des
collectivités territoriales européennes
je crois qu'il y en a 101.000 100 et
quelques aujourd'hui et nous nous
n'avons plus de 36000 donc encore 40%.
et quand on a inventé l'intercommunalité
si ma mémoire est bonne c'était bien la
réponse à l'émiments des collectivités
locales et de dire que quelque part en
créant non pas une collectivité de plein
exercice mais un établissement public de
coopération intercommunale même si dans
la loi ma femme il y a une nouvelle
collectivité qui a été créée c'est la
seule c'est notamment la métropole de
Lyon et d'ailleurs vous verrez que dans
les questions sur les centralisation il
y a des parlementaires qui vont reposer
la question de création de nouvelles
collectivités
doit-on apporter la même organisation
territoriale de la République en
fonction du territoire pour lequel on se
trouve est-ce qu'on peut faire des
différences entre la l'agglomération
parisienne Rhône-Alpes ou d'autres
territoires qui ne sont pas
historiquesment démographiquement
économiquement socialement pas tout à
fait
identique là-dessus il peut y avoir mon
avis ça me choque pas des avis
complètement différents et j'en viens
sur la terre communalité si on va
regarder des choses soit
l'intercommunalité d'ailleurs
souvenez-vous Edward balladir n'en
saurapport avait dit quelque part ça
valait pour les intercommunalités y
compris pour les départements à terme il
avait utilisé il y aura une évaporation
des communes et du département c'était
en un mot une aspiration quelque part
d'un certain nombre de compétences des
communes de plus en plus nombreuses vers
la terre communalité qui faisait que il
faut dire les choses franchement c'était
quelque part une conception que la
Communauté de Communes devenait de la
commune du 21e siècle avec la
disparition interne des communes bon
alors aujourd'hui on en est pas là mais
si on regarde aujourd'hui la
caractéristique des intercommunalités
vous en avez trois juridiquement vous
avez les communautés urbaines vous avez
les communautés de l'agglo et vous avez
des communautés de communes plutôt
rurales semi rural etc
si pour les compétences des départements
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui a été voulu dans
la loi pour les métropoles c'est de dire
qu'à ce niveau là pourquoi les
métropoles n'auraient-elles pas les
compétences du département c'est une
vraie question mais j'ai interrogé comme
président l'adnf un président de
l'association des communautés urbaines
dont j'ai pu percevoir que la réponse
était pas
encourageante sur l'idée de prendre les
responsabilités sociales des
départements parce que les communautés
urbaines étaient plutôt sur les enjeux
notamment de la formation supérieure des
grands enjeux économiques de stratégie
etc et que il y avait une spécialisation
et une grande expérience qui avait été
acquise dans les départements pourquoi
c'est intéressant l'espace départemental
c'est qu'il ne peut pas y avoir une
association
une action sociale des campagnes et une
action sociale des vignes
la réalité de l'action sociale dans des
territoires c'est qu'on a su combiner
les solidarités tant pour le monde
urbain que pour le monde rural et là il
y a une véritable harmonie et c'est l'un
des succès d'ailleurs du social dans les
départements je dis pas que ce soit
homogène partout
parce que je termine sur le sujet à
partir du moment où on a accepté la
décentralisation ça veut dire que on
considère que les différences dans les
choix politiques sont possibles et qu'on
n'est pas forcé de faire la même
politique dans un département que dans
l'autre si on n'accepte pas ça il y a
pas de décentralisation il faut à mon
avis c'est mon point de vue sur le sujet
Gérard Longuet à propos de la
répartition des
de trouver l'équilibre entre les hommes
et les espaces
exercices difficiles on l'a vu par
exemple pour la réforme du mode de
scrutin pour les départements où il y a
eu un débat très long entre le -20 + 20
je sais qu'ici il y avait des
adeptes du + 30 - 30 qui me paraissait
plus juste pour essayer de mieux
équilibrer mais ça veut dire que demain
pour les régions et pour le futur il
faut regarder quelque part de très après
des pondérations pour que effectivement
des départements puisque la
circonscription départementale elle
n'est pas enlevée et bien qu'il y ait
quelque part un bon équilibre entre les
espaces et en oubliant jamais que les
espaces sont des espaces vivants et que
ça bouge et que on n'est pas voué à
l'inégulable parce que on habite un
département rural mais il y a aussi là
aussi de la de la vitalité je crois que
je suis à peu près allé jusqu'au bout
quelqu'un m'a demandé est-ce que vous
êtes pour la suppression des
départements et après quelqu'un qui m'a
posé cette question là enfin je veux
dire qu'est-ce que je fais à la tête de
la DF
si tel était le cas je donne ma
démission immédiatement ça veut dire que
quelque part je crois beaucoup à cette
collectivité de proximité et
je crois que elle a toute sa pertinence
d'autant plus que j'attire votre
attention mais ça vous le saviez déjà
c'est la première fois où nous pourrions
supprimer une collectivité
dont les élus sont élus au suffrage
universel ce qui ne sait jamais vu
jusqu'à présent et ce serait la première
fois ça veut dire que c'est pas parce
qu'il y a pas eu une première fois qu'il
veut pas y en avoir mais c'est aussi
cette réalité après pour Ronan dans tech
sur le devenir des régions
on n'est pas l'état fédéral
je pense qu'on est toujours un État
unitaire décentralisé d'ailleurs il y a
une modification de la Constitution qui
reconnaît la République des centralisée
votée en 2004 ou 2006
à l'époque moi j'ai une interrogation
qui est pour le devenir des régions
je ne voudrais pas qu'on substitue
un État jacobin
des régions qui demain de venir
pourraient devenir des petits étages à
coma je crois que là il y a il y a
quelque part un risque qui pourrait
apparaître et puis je termine sur une
conclusion très personnelle et je l'ai
dit d'ailleurs à qui de droit et tant au
Premier ministre que au président de la
République
cette loi de décentralisation n'est pas
dans le sens de l'histoire
c'est la première fois où il y aura pas
de nouveaux transfert de compétences de
l'État à l'endroit des collectivités
territoriales et c'est ça que je trouve
que on est dans une loi de clarification
on est dans une loi de confirmation mais
on n'est pas dans une loi des
centralisation et moi j'aurais voulu
qu'on discute de l'enseignement
supérieur j'aurais voulu qu'on discute
de la compétence de santé pourquoi pas
que le service public de l'emploi aurait
été plus placé sur la double autorité du
président de Région et du préfet de
région enfin je veux dire il y a des tas
de sujets qu'on aurait pu aborder comme
si on avait peur du collectivités
territoriales et notamment de leurs élus
et de leurs administrations et vous
verrez que si à mon point de vue notre
France pourra s'en sortir que si demain
on est véritablement un pays beaucoup
plus décentralisé et je terminerai sur
ce point la France est classée 17e au
niveau des 28 pays de l'Union d'Europe
plus des centralisé ça veut dire qu'on
est les derniers de la classe et dans
les six pays les plus peuplés on est
très loin des autres et nous savons bien
les uns les autres il suffit de prendre
un certain nombre de critères qui sont
très objectif je vais pas mettre sur le
sujet mais c'est là à mon avis que
repose l'une des grandes questions d'un
véritable progrès de la décentralisation
et qui était à mon avis attendu car
c'était pour aussi pour répondre à un
défi au-delà de la démocratie c'était la
question de la lutte contre le chômage
du développement de nos territoires et
du développement de nos entreprises très
bien merci monsieur le Président Madame
la vice-président
comment
a perdu la question votre question s'est
perdu monsieur Lecam je suis désolé mais
on va la retrouver les communes
voilà c'est ça voilà bon et puis bientôt
il y aura plus beaucoup de
parlementaires quand on aura
l'interdiction de cumuler des fonctions
bon avançons allez
monsieur Jarlier vous avez seul la
parole bien merci monsieur le Président
tout d'abord je voudrais excuser le
présent Jacques Pélissard qui continue
d'aider de convocation on n'a pas pu se
libérer ensuite je voudrais aussi vous
dire au départ que le bureau de l'AMF
n'a pas eu l'occasion compte tenu des
délais aussi de se prononcer sur ce
texte rassurez-vous nous à peine voilà
donc
c'est donc un certain nombre de
réflexion que je peux vous livrer qui
sont liés plus à des discussions
informelles qui a une position
évidemment du bureau de la famille du
bureau de l'AMF qui doit débattre de ce
sujet dans dans quelques jours un
premier point quand même
nous allons aujourd'hui évoquer donc le
sujet qui touche la délimitation des
régions
et en fait nous nous aurions aimé mais
c'est un vieux
avoir une vision globale avec une
possibilité bien sûr d'analyse à la fois
de l'impact sur les compétences sur les
moyens sur les représentations avant
même que l'on passe à une un texte qui
touche véritablement véritablement le
côté électoral et et l'AMF a dit
plusieurs fois qu'on aurait voulu plutôt
avoir un grand texte fondateur puis
après des textes opérationnels qui nous
auraient permis d'avoir une meilleure
lisibilité et je dois vous dire très
sincèrement que ça fait partie un petit
peu des inquiétudes des élus c'est aussi
ce manque de lisibilité
à long terme de ce qui se passera sur
nos institutions parce que il n'y a pas
à un moment ou une écriture précise de
notre futur organisation territoriale
sur un seul texte donc c'est un
préalable deuxième préalable les élus à
l'AMF pensent comme beaucoup d'élus
locaux que une réforme territoriale est
indispensable bien sûr mais aussi
indissociable d'une réforme de l'État
notamment d'une réforme de la présence
de l'État sur le territoire comment
imaginer demain une réorganisation
territoriale des collectivités sans
savoir de quelle façon ces collectivités
seront accompagnées par l'État avec
quelle représentation territoriale je
vais revenir peut-être ensuite
s'agissant plus particulièrement des
régions
pour nous la question de la taille n'est
finalement pas aussi importante que
celle des compétences
et celle des moyens qui seront donnés
assez régions et pour nous donc c'est
bien la question de l'organisation qui
est la plus importante donc je voudrais
évoquer très rapidement parce qu'en fait
je pense qu'on aura un échange très
rapidement 4 ou 5 points qui nous
semblent assez majeurs pour les cellules
locaux pour les mères la question de la
clarification la question de la
représentation la question de la
proximité nécessaire de la subsidiarité
et de solidarité alors bien sûr
l'arrivée de grande région on peut
toujours
s'interroger on voit bien que
d'ailleurs nous on n'a pas une j'allais
dire on n'a pas une une position
arrêtée sur ce sujet parce qu'elle
dépend évidemment
des décisions qui sont prises localement
d'abord mais on voit bien que quel que
soit les gouvernements moitié en place
tous les rapports parlementaires ont
bien sent bien arrivé à la même
conclusion que
l'idée de grande région était quand même
relativement indispensable pour pouvoir
avoir des territoires capables d'égaler
les grandes régions européennes que ce
soit le rapport Raffarin balader ça doit
être dit à nombreuses reprises ici
simplement ce que nous déplorons un peu
et qui interroge aussi beaucoup d'éluses
c'est la méthode avec laquelle
aujourd'hui on nous propose se découpage
et certains que même si le choix est
difficile
on aurait peut-être préféré avoir des
débat d'abord préalablement au sein de
nos territoires pour voir comment les
choses pouvaient se passer et
effectivement comment on pouvait
envisager de nouvelles solidarités il y
a deux
sujets qui interrogent les élus
le premier sujet c'est l'éloignement des
territoires et des centres de décision
en gros qui sera l'interlocuteur comment
le territoire s'organisera notamment les
territoires de proximité je vais revenir
et puis le deuxième sujet c'est aussi la
représentation c'est-à-dire que on voit
bien qu'avec ce qui se dessine il y aura
moins d'élus pour représenter des
territoires plus grands
je vais y revenir et cela nous semble
une des grandes difficultés évidemment
de l'exercice auquel nous devons nous
livrer maintenant un mot sur la
clarification
je donne deux exemples parce que le
sujet n'est pas de traiter des
compétences aujourd'hui si j'ai bien si
j'ai bien compris donc je rentrerai pas
trop dans ce détail mais enfin les élus
sont en attente quand même d'une
tarification des compétences de chaque
rendre collectivité je donnais deux
exemples premier exemple lorsque nous
montons des projets de territoire au
sein de nos intercommunalités
aujourd'hui nous faisons un premier
travail avec le département avec ses
propres critères avec ses propres
attentes avec ses propres schémas et
puis lorsque nous allons contracter avec
la région nous faisons un deuxième
projet de territoire avec ses propres
critères ses propres attentes et à un
moment il faut croiser tout ça et la
cohérence du développement local se pose
parce qu'il y a pas toujours
compatibilité aujourd'hui entre les deux
objectifs qui sont fixés soit dans la
région soit dans le département donc il
y a évidemment un moment intérêt d'avoir
à faire à un interlocuteur en matière
d'aménagement du territoire et de
développement local de façon à ce que on
puisse réaliser des
projet de territoire qui soit en phase
avec ces grandes stratégies deuxième
exemple le transport scolaire je prends
cet exemple parce que on est quand même
dans un dispositif qui est un peu
compliqué
aujourd'hui le département gère le
transport scolaire il délègue a des
gestionné à proximité avec les
intercommunalités elles s'occupe de
gérer la sécurité elle s'occupe bien
souvent c'est comme ça en tout cas ça
arrive chez nous c'est comme ça
l'intercommunalité l'intercommunalité
s'occupe de la compét
ences l'intercommunalité s'occupe de
gérer les circuits de gérer la
sécurité de gérer le suivi avec les
familles et c'est le Conseil Général
c'est le terme et c'est est-ce que je
peux
l'occasion
poserez vos questions laissez le laisser
de l'orateur s'exprimer ça existe s'il
vous plaît je vous donne un exemple de
ce qui doit exister quelque part puisque
je le connais donc et je l'ai même vécu
d'accord mais en tout cas alors je vais
essayer de finir le une chose est sûre
c'est qu'on a un gestionnaire de
proximité qui délégué par le Département
le geste de proximité assure évidemment
le quotidien du du service c'est pas lui
qui donne les marchés et surtout le
problème c'est que c'est le Conseil
Général qui décide des tarifs et lorsque
l'intercommunalité par exemple décide
d'appliquer un tarif unique et bien elle
est obligé d'envoyer un chèque à toutes
les familles pour pouvoir effectivement
assurer une tarification attractive
c'est la réalité de ce qui se passe sur
le terrain parce que à un moment et bien
on donne à deux strates différentes le
soin d'organiser un service je prends
cet exemple parce que je l'ai vécu sur
le terrain et malheureusement ça ne
marche pas très très bien je m'arrête là
sur la clarification parce qu'on voit
bien que concrètement il y a des sujets
qui nécessitent d'être traités même si
ça nécessite
c'est le président même si ça nécessite
un certain nombre de remise en cause
sans doute de pratiques
actuelles s'agissons de la
représentation des territoires un sujet
qui pour nous est un sujet quand même
extrêmement sensible et là je voudrais
vous donner l'exemple de ce qui se passe
en Auvergne avec le texte de loi alors
aujourd'hui nous avons cinq élus
régionaux sur un total de 47
en Auvergne on voit que avec le texte
nous aurions trois élus régionaux dans
le meilleur des cas dans le meilleur des
cas avec un total pour l'Auvergne de 26
élus soit 45% de moins qu'aujourd'hui
alors même que en région Rhône-Alpes
ça ne fera un diminution que de 20%.
donc non seulement on va avoir un
territoire qui sera plus grand avec un
secteur pur rural qui va intégrer mais
la représentation d'une région pureurale
sera
affaiblie beaucoup plus que ne le sera
la représentation de la région
Rhône-Alpes alors on voit bien que il y
a là une vraie difficulté et ça nous
pose un vrai problème de représentation
des territoires ruraux et les maires
sont inquiets sur ce sujet ils sont pas
opposés à ce que on aille rejoindre une
grande région après les choix
stratégiques c'est une autre affaire
mais par contre il voit d'un très
mauvais œil qu'il n'y ait plus de
proximité et de représentativité de
proximité au sein donc de ces de ces
régions
pour ce sujet nous pourrions
éventuellement proposer des adaptations
et on envisageait deux pistes
la première pourrait être celle de faire
coïncider le nombre d'élus et le nombre
de candidats
ce qui aurait qui figure le nombre de
candidats qui figurent un article 6 du
projet de loi ça aurait un incidence
assez faible mais qui amènerait à passer
de 150 à 166 conseillers régionaux au
plan national en faisant ça on ne serait
que on ne passerait que de 1611 à 1805
conseillers régionaux je rappelle que
avec la loi sur le conseiller
territorial nous étions à
3480 conseillers territoriaux donc nous
sommes loin du compte en essayant
d'apporter une meilleure
représentativité des des territoires
j'ajoute que si on allait dans cette
direction
si on allait dans cette direction il
faudrait évidemment introduire un
scrutin départemental pour éviter qu'il
y ait une variable d'ajustement en
fonction des scores régionaux parce que
sinon évidemment on ne serait pas sûr
que chaque candidat puisse être élu au
regard de tableau qui est présenté ça
c'est la première formule il y a une
deuxième éventualité qui pourrait être
celle d'assurer un seuil minimum d'élus
par département de ou 3 en trouvant une
formule qui répondent évidemment aux
impératifs
constitutionnels ce qui est peut-être
pas le plus facile mais évidemment dans
ce cas il faudrait aussi revenir à un
scrutin des départementales voilà donc
sur ce sujet de la de la
représentativité les mers sont très
attachés à ce qu'il puisse être
représenté par des conseillers régionaux
suffisants il y a des territoires qui
sont extrêmement ruraux
qui sont extrêmement grands sur le plan
des distances entre les villes et la
campagne et qui méritent évidemment
d'être représenté tout à fait
équitablement ensuite je voudrais
évoquer le problème de la proximité
il y a évidemment pour nous mère premier
échelon de la démocratie locale nous
nous pensons que toute réforme doit être
faite en tenant compte d'un certain
esprit de solidarité sur lequel je
reviendrai et nous pensons que c'est
bien à partir du bloc communal qu'il
faut organiser notre démocratie de
proximité et que sans doute ce bloc
communal doit évoluer mais il doit
évoluer selon nous non pas avec de la
supracommunalité mais avec des communes
plus fortes et des intercommunalités
plus fortes alors sur ce sujet le
président pélissar a d'ailleurs déposé
une proposition de loi pour encourager
les communes nouvelles et nous
regrettons que ce texte n'est pas fait
l'objet déjà d'un débat et nous espérons
que ce texte pourra être intégré dans le
deuxième texte qui sera présenté à
l'automne parce que c'est très important
pourquoi
on voit bien que aujourd'hui dans
certains territoires ruraux il y a un
certain nombre de communes qui n'ont
plus un nombre suffisant d'habitants
pour assurer les charges quotidiennes
auxquelles elles ont à faire face elles
n'ont plus les moyens de fonctionner et
les mères en sont conscient il y a
aujourd'hui un mouvement de solidarité
qui existe et il y a même des maires qui
pensent à se regrouper évidemment il
faut que tout ça soit fait au plan
volontaire parce que à chaque fois qu'on
fait un mariage forcé de toute façon il
ne fonctionne pas on l'a vu avec la loi
Marcellin qui n'a pas du tout fonctionné
donc il faut un autre modèle et ce
modèle de commune nouvelle il peut
fonctionner pourquoi parce qu'il
permettra à la fois de créer des entités
plus fortes capables demain d'assumer la
compétence générale à laquelle nous
sommes tous très attachés sur le bloc
communal et il permettra aussi dans
certains cas à des communes nouvelles
qui se sont déjà regroupées de rentrer
dans des intercommunalités en faisant
plus fort à l'intérieur des terres
communautés qui seront plus grandes
voilà le sens de ce que propose le
président pélissar qui me semble être
une évolution intéressante fondée sur le
volontariat et les dispositifs qui sont
proposés permettent dans la période de
transition puisque nous avons déjà fait
les élections d'organiser quand même ces
communes nouvelles avec des gouvernances
de transition avec un certain nombre
d'incitations pour pour les constituer
donc premier élément effectivement la
commune nouvelle deuxième élément
l'intercommunalité
nous pensons à la MF je pense que c'est
un sujet qui est partagé avec la DCF que
si nous voulons demain constituer des
j'allais dire des partenaires des
régions des partenaires de l'aménagement
du territoire on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui le développement local
s'organise autour d'intercommunalités
qui sont fortes et nous pensons que ces
communautés doivent être effectivement
renforcées
la question du seuil se pose et pour
nous les choses sont claires il ne faut
surtout pas imposer un seuil qui ne
tiendrait pas compte de la diversité des
territoires parce que bien entendu il y
a des territoires à faibles densité qui
méritent sans doute de nouvelles
solidarités peut-être pas à l'échelle de
20 000 habitants parce que pour vous
donner un exemple il y a certaines
communautés qui pour arriver à 15 16 ou
20 000 habitants devraient rassembler au
moins 80-90 communes voire plus alors ça
pose une question de distance de
gouvernance partagée quand vous voyez la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel qui
vient de tomber sur la représentativité
au sein des intercos qui va remettre en
cause énormément de fusion parce que les
équilibres auxquels on était arrivé vont
être remis en cause on voit bien que
plus on sera nombreux autour de la table
plus ce sera compliqué pour trouver une
gouvernance
équitable surtout si on ne peut pas
moduler le fameux tableau qui a été mis
en place sur lequel nous avons beaucoup
discuté avec le rapporteur à l'époque et
pour lequel l'AMF c'était beaucoup battu
pour qu'on obtienne justement des
dérogations qui aujourd'hui sont remises
en cause par le Conseil constitutionnel
donc nous voulons des intercommunalités
fortes qui seront demain des
interlocuteurs de la région pour pouvoir
contractualiser des projets de
développement directement en lien avec
les stratégies qui seront évidemment
constitués voilà moi ce que je
souhaitais vous dire sur le problème de
la de la de la de la proximité étant
entendu que je souhaiterais ajouter une
chose importante il faut dissocier les
départements et encore une fois je pense
qu'il faut pas qu'on confonde le
département et le Conseil général parce
que c'est quand même deux choses
différentes
non c'est pas la même chose parce que
les départements a été créé par l'État
pour représenter l'état et Monsieur le
je fais la même observation qu'à votre
prédécesseur une collectivité locale
c'est un des compétences et une
assemblée élue autrement ça dépend une
collectivité territoriale vous pouvez
dire tout ce que vous voulez le
département est constitutionnellement
constitué comme la Région et la commune
les autres ne le sont pas alors si on
veut supprimer le département où
l'assemblée du département il faut une
révision constitutionnelle point elle se
présente c'est parce que c'est surtout
pas ce que je vais dire donc voilà donc
je suis tout à fait pour en parler parce
que c'est pas ce que je vais dire ce que
je veux dire c'est que
dans le département qui sont des
départements ruraux en secteur urbain la
question se pose pas dans les
départements qui sont des départements
ruraux on voit bien que la taille des
intercommunalités ne permettra pas
d'obtenir la la taille suffisante pour
pouvoir justement mener à la fois des
politiques de développement efficaces en
matière de service notamment et sans
doute pour pouvoir relayer des
compétences qui seront peut-être
attribués à un moment à un échelon
supérieur donc nous pensons qu'il est
absolument indispensable qu'il existe un
échelon départemental qui pourrait être
constitué des intercommunalités par
exemple et oui qui pourrait être
constitué des représentants
d'intercommunalité et qui pourrait donc
constituer une entité départementale
qui sera une évolution du conseil
général en réalité
et alors et qui en même temps
pour être à la même échelle à la même
échelle que le département avec la
présence de l'État il est important
qu'il y a un pendant de la
représentation de l'État au sein du
département puisque aujourd'hui on nous
dit que l'État veut renforcer sa
présence à l'échelle départementale il
est important qu'il y ait une
représentation territoriale à la même
échelle pour que effectivement il puisse
se mettre en place des partenariats
efficaces voilà sur le sujet donc de la
de la proximité et de cette façon il y
aurait une possibilité peut-être de
rassurer beaucoup d'élus qui voit avec
la suppression du département s'éloigner
les centres de décision donc mon propos
n'était pas de penser à leur suppression
mais alors rénovation voilà oui mais
c'est ce que je dis
je me permettrai pas
ensuite s'agissant de la subsidiarité
les élus les mers sont très attachés au
fait que l'on puisse maintenir des liens
dearité de façon à ce que chaque échelon
du territoire soit parti prenantes
notamment dans les grandes stratégies
d'aménagement du territoire on parle
sans rentrer dans les compétences on
part de schéma régional d'aménagement de
territoire c'est vrai que sans doute
c'est un sujet extrêmement important que
c'est ce qui va en fait conditionner
l'efficacité demain d'une politique
d'aménagement du territoire faut-il
encore que ce schéma soit constitué avec
l'apport bien sûr du bloc local l'apport
du bloc local de façon à ce que si
demain ils devaient être prescriptif on
soit dans un système de co-construction
et qui est pas donc de difficultés
ensuite d'acceptation et de mise en
œuvre surtout
quand ensuite ces schémas régionaux et
je pense que le triptyque est bon vont
être décliné à l'intérieur des schémas
de cohérence territoriaux puis ensuite
des pluies ou des pluies selon les choix
qui seront faits on a là un véritable
maillage de la planification qui devrait
permettre d'améliorer considérablement
les conditions d'aménagement du
territoire
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
spéciale du Sénat sur la réforme
territoriale nous y reviendrons plus
largement dans notre journal à 19h mais
tout de suite c'est preuve par 3
l'émission politique de la rédaction de
Public Sénat en partenariat avec l'AFP
qui reçoit ce soir Pierre Laurent
secrétaire national du Parti communiste
français et sénateur de Paris à tout à
l'heure